So we were offline talking about
Stalin and, uh,
the evils of the Soviet regime. Yeah.
One of the things I mentioned, I watched the movie, uh, Mr. Jones,
but it's about the 1930s called the more the,
what would you say? The torture of the Ukrainian people? Yeah.
By Stalin one interesting thing to me,
I'd love to hear your opinion about is the role of journalism in all of this,
and also about 1930s Germany.
So what's the role of journalists and intellectuals
in a time when trouble is brewing,
but it requires a really sort of
brave and deep thinking to understand that trouble is brewing.
Like if you were a journalist or if you were just like an intellectual,
a thinker. Sure. But also a voice of, uh, in the,
in the space of public discourse,
what would you do in 1930s about Stalin,
about how the more,
and what would you do about Nazi Germany in 1937,
1938.
So that's really funny that you asked that because currently how the book is
structured, it's like, you know, books often follow a three X structure, right?
So act three is the eighties act.
One is the thirties and act two is going to be like, all right,
let's suppose you were in the thirties. Are you just going to give up? Like,
are you just going to be like, well, we're screwed and you'd be right to say,
things are going to be very loud for a long time.
Or are you going to be one of those few who are like,
we're going to do something about this. And you know,
we're going to go down swinging. There are two books I can recommend,
which are just masterpieces, that, that are written by women.
Um, that just are historians that are just superb.
There's a book called beyond belief by Deborah Lipstadt.
She talks about the rise of Nazi Germany as seen through the press and what
was amazing.
And she's does a great job empathizing with the press and understand their
perspective is we remember and Chamberlain gets a bad rap,
Neville Chamberlain for kind of appeasing Hitler, because not that long ago,
they had the great war.
They had world war one and they had the carnage that the earth had never
seen before. And when you had people made out of meat,
meaning industrial machines and plastic surgery was invented as a consequence of
this they're coming back mangled and disfigured and for what,
and this was a world where the Kaiser was the most evil person who ever lived.
And we all had the Western propaganda about the Hahn and all the rapes and all
this barbarism and blah, blah, blah.
So not that long later when you're hearing all this propaganda,
which was factual about Hitler, it's like, we heard this,
we heard this 20 years ago, this was all lies. Give us some,
give us a break.
And she has all the quotes from the different agencies and
how they address their plus. They had very limited information.
It's not like Nazi,
Germany was an open society where reporters can walk around and they were under
a lot of pressure as well. You know, in those areas.
Hitler himself was pretty good at, uh, he let some stuff slip,
but usually he made it seem like he wants peace. He wants world peace. This one.
It's amazing.
They were making the argument that because all these Jews were being beaten up
on the street,
this proved this was the hot take of the day that Hitler was weak
because since Hitler's a statesman and he can't control these hooligans that
shows his control and power is tenuous.
And this is all going to go away by the way.
I mean, Hitler thought that too,
he was kind of afraid of the bronchitis or whatever.
Like he was afraid of these hooligans a little bit.
Like there were useful to him, but like at a certain point, like, yeah,
they can get in the way. Yeah.
That's why he wanted to get control of the military, the army,
like their regiment. Like if you want to take over the world,
you can't do it with hooligans. Right. You have to do it with an actual.
Sure. Army. And then you had Kristallnacht, which was a nationwide pogrom.
And then all the news agencies universally were like, Oh crap.
We were, we, we got this wrong. And the condemnation was universal.
So that book traces, uh,
the West reaction to what's going on there and including the reaction to the,
uh, incipient Holocaust as people being, you know, what they knew,
when did they know there was not ambiguity about it? People,
I think there's this myth that she dispels that piece,
that they didn't know the Holocaust was happening, where they didn't care.
They were aware, but they were already at war with Nazi Germany.
Like what literally, what else could they do at that point? Um, you know, to,
to rescue all these Jews. So, so th that's the super book and Anne Applebaum,
I think the book is called red famine came out fairly recently and
she brings the receipts and she's, uh, you know,
this is something I really hate with the binary thinkers,
where the people think, Oh, you know, if you're a Democrat,
you're basically a communist. They call Joe Biden, the Marxist. It's just like,
you know, she's a hard left day. She's, you know, has TDS,
but this book just systemically lays out what Stalin did.
By the way. I'm triggered by the binary thinkers. And for those who don't know,
TDS zero, zero one, one is a Trump derangement syndrome. Yes.
So they, you know, forced to starvation its entire population.
And they, it's not only that,
it's like they knew if you weren't starving by looking at you that you
were hiding food.
So then come back to your house at night and break your fingers in the door or
take burn down your house.
And now you're on the street without food because you lied.
Cause this is the people's food. You're a, Kulak, you're a landowner.
And very quickly a Kulak which meant like peasant landowner became anyone who
had a piece of bread and it was systemic and ongoing.
And many people in the press did not believe it. Uh,
there was a, um, a British journalist, I believe who got out of the train, uh,
Ukraine,
like one town earlier and walked and he described all this and he was mocked and
derided. And this is just anti-Russian propaganda.
Because at the time in the thirties,
this was socialism had come through fruition. This was a noble experiment.
I'd seen the future. And it works. I think, uh,
Sydney web was the guy who said that. And the premise was,
let's see what happens. We've never tried something like that.
And they were perfectly happy to have this experiment happen overseas at the
price of the Russian people, because it's like, you know what,
maybe this will be paradise on earth. And there's a,
I address this in my book as well. There's suburb essay,
I think by Eugene Genovese. And, uh, he talks about the question,
the question being, what did you know? And when did you know it,
what did you know about the concentration camps?
What did you know about the starvation? What'd, you know,
about children being taught at school to turn in their parents were, you know,
having some extra bread and his conclusion is we all knew and we all knew from
the beginning, every bit of it.
And we didn't care because we were more interested in promoting this ideology.
So when people are kind of thinking,
the worst thing on earth is like Robert E.
Lee statue being taken out of Washington, DC.
We were being told on a,
an especially a much more limited news information world,
where now you have literally anyone have a Twitter,
but how many outlets were there that this is, uh, we're backwards.
They're the future they're scientific. We have the vagaries of the market,
which led to the great depression.
And when you see what was being put over on the American public at the time, um,
anyone who thinks things are as bad now, as they ever,
ever been is simply delusional or ignorant.